meantime back here in the u.s rescue
workers are working non-stop in
louisiana and mississippi to help those
affected by hurricane ida after it
slammed into louisiana yesterday as a
category 4 hurricane wind speeds topping
150 miles per hour hurricane ida had the
potential to be one of the more powerful
storms to make landfall in the u.s
senior correspondent mike tobin is in
new orleans tonight good evening mike
good evening bretton the number of
people killed by hurricane ida has just
risen to two as the health department
has confirmed a drowning victim still
rescuers are fearful that relatively low
number could rise as they struggle to
reach the area's hardest hit by ida
hurricane ida slammed into louisiana
sunday as a cat 4 storm on the 16th
anniversary of hurricane katrina it was
loud
we could hear the wind um we could hear
things hitting the house hitting the
vehicle
i heard a lot of crashing sounds
waves slammed into this dock in port
fouchon high winds wreaked havoc downing
power lines ripping pieces of metal off
buildings and uprooting trees throughout
southern louisiana a levee failed in
lafitte south of new orleans a bridge
damaged there as well leaving over 200
people in imminent danger from the high
waters necessitating rescue the
slow-moving storm is still causing
flooding throughout the region and
tornadoes remain a threat president
biden meeting virtually with governors
and the fema administrator noted that
more than 5 000 guardsmen have been
called up generators are being sent even
drones are being used to assess damage
to the power grid folks get knocked down
we're there to help you get back on your
feet the most important element though
is coordinating all the branches of
government in new orleans bourbon street
was left littered with debris buildings
in other areas of the city collapsed and
huge trees were uprooted including one
that survived hurricane katrina but one
thing was clear this hurricane was not
katrina so far we have not had reports
of massive loss
of life but we did have a tragedy where
we believe an individual was driving a
car
and therefore drown that may be due to
the more than 14 billion spent by the
federal government after katrina to
rebuild the levees protecting the city
making them bigger and stronger and far
more capable of withstanding huge
storms levee systems particularly our
federal levy systems and hurricane risk
reduction systems performed
magnificently
the entergy company says the eight major
transmission lines that supply power to
new orleans suffered catastrophic damage
during the storm even one that spanned
the mississippi and withstood katrina
two million people are without power 4
500 workers are on the ground no
estimate for when the lights will be
back on brett that's a big deal mike the
the power obviously and having covered
hurricane katrina 16 years ago
it's a much different deal with with the
levees right now so the big issue down
there right now is power
the big issue is power and one of the
things to look for uh the uh the uh the
pumps that drain uh the city of new
orleans those function the storm pumps
those function but the sewage pumps are
dependent on the power grid so you could
start to have a a health emergency here
if they don't get those things online
and pumping soon right we'll follow that
closely mike tobin in new orleans thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else